Parliament will hold the final vote on
two Landmark bills the Digital Services
Act and the digital markets act they'll
provide a fairer online framework
limiting the powers of big internet
platforms like search engines and make
digital markets safer and more
competitive
MEPS will discuss the recent decision to
Grant Ukraine and Moldova EU candidate
status a move backed by parliament in
June they'll also assess developments in
three accession countries in the western
Balkans
members will decide whether to veto
commission plans to list certain nuclear
and gas projects as environmentally
sustainable if voted down the commission
would need to redraft or withdraw the
so-called taxonomy rules
Czech prime minister Petra fiala will
outline his country's priorities for the
next six months as Prague takes over the
rotating presidency of the council from
France
Parliament will vote on its proposals to
better support mental health in the age
of digital technology and homeworking
MEPS argue that while both bring
benefits more should be done to improve
work-life balance and prevent stress
anxiety and depression
[Music]